foreign
let's go to Arizona and talk to Jordan
what's up Jordan
Hi how are you I'm good how are you
pretty good all right so what's up
all right my husband and I have a
three-month-old daughter and he's really
really grateful but there are times that
um fairly often he gets really
frustrated um so fast like so frustrated
so fast with himself when she's crying
that he can't calm her or whatever's
going on and then he just shuts down for
the rest of the day
um because in his words he thought he'd
be better than this and I've tried to
encourage him to tell him that he really
is doing great she's a baby she can only
cry she can't communicate that way and
he's not really doing anything wrong he
just gets so frustrated with himself
um because he thought he'd be better and
he's so good with the nieces and his
nephews but he's struggling with his own
child is this your first kid
yes oh my gosh can you have him call me
because I've been here I've been here
yeah oh man
and I've told him it's all so normal
um but he just can't get past it
sometimes in his own head and he just
gets stuck there like in his own head
and he's in his words he gets like
depressed yeah every day or so and then
he'll come back but I just don't know
and I guess my question is how to keep
encouraging him without you know telling
him what to do or to be degrading I just
want him to know he's actually doing
well and then you know not get so hurt
and like down on himself yes
um all of this is easier said than done
and here's my guess you said he's really
good with nieces and nephews is he the
is he like the the fun uncle
um they're all fun he's one of um five
of them oh man all right so here's I'll
tell you because he's on the phone with
me so I'll just speak to you and to the
people listening okay number one thank
you so much for calling this is a call
one of those calls that
um will end up doing really well because
it's gonna help a lot of folks okay
um
your husband has probably been telling
himself for a long time he's going to be
better than all the other dads
and he is going to be the dad who shows
up and is present with his daughter and
he is going to raise a great daughter
right am I on the right track
yeah he's going to be the dad and he's
got some experience with kids not real
experience but pretend experience he's
played and got a lot of laughs and done
some wrestling and he is the cool cool
one of several cool uncles and so it
gives a false sense of what the day in
and day out is like and then you have a
newborn
that is basically like a wet potato that
screams right it's it's just like a
towel and
I was wholly unprepared for how
um
what a complete failure I was but here's
why I chalked up success to
I could get my daughter and son to stop
crying they would smile when I came in
the room they would always want to reach
out to me and even though I would never
say this out loud I wanted to be the
cool parent I wanted my kids when they
were like three months four months five
months old when they don't even know
what's
they know nothing other than food sleep
and
Cha-Cha right
um I want to be the cool I want to be
like the dad that the kid reached for
instead of mom and I would be like sorry
hun he loves me more or she loves me
like whatever and none of that happened
because I have no food I yeah none of it
happened
and so here was a huge Bellwether moment
for me
I I came home from class one day and it
was one I was getting another I was back
in grad school again like an idiot and
um my son was two I think and I came
home and he was waddle walking you know
as they do and he could say a few words
he's a pretty late talker and he shows
up at the front door as I'm walking in
and I said hey Bubba come give me a hug
because I wanted to be that Dad that
always came in and dropped all my stuff
and was present with the kids and blah
blah blah blah and he looked at me and
said no daddy and he turns and Sprints
down the hall in his little waddle
walkie way
come to think about it our our favorite
game his only way of engaging with me
right because I don't have food and his
way of engaging with me was playing tag
playing hide and seek playing silly
rambunctious games and so his way of
saying I love you and I'm so glad to see
you was let's go right into playing a
game
and when he said no Daddy and turned off
down the hallway my first thought in my
mind was of course because you suck at
being a dad
you're never here you're not right and
then this internal dialogue about how
lame I was starts I'm gonna be a failure
just like every other stupid dad my own
son doesn't even want to hug me and now
I'm off to the races right so here was
the big moment for me and I'm saying
this and you can pass this along to your
husband just know he's not going to hear
you there's no way he hears this okay
but it'll feel good for you to say it
out loud
the phrase here he doesn't get a vote
she doesn't get a vote why because she's
three months old
and she doesn't have permission to hurt
my feelings and it took me a while with
my son and then when my daughter came
along it was she's it was even more hard
because she she weaponizes love because
she's my little girl and she's hilarious
about it
um
but I had to decide my children don't
have permission to hurt my feelings
and that was the magic for me
and now I can say
um hey uh this is what we're having for
dinner I'm not eating that it's yuck
um that's not knock your lights out I
worked really hard on this I think it's
delicious and so this is what we're
having and I'm not gonna let you hurt my
feelings because as a society we have
decided because your brains don't work
properly you can't drink you can't buy
beer you can't uh buy guns lottery
tickets you can't sign contracts and so
why in the world would I give you access
to
my feelings and emotions you see what
I'm saying
yeah so this is something your husband's
gonna have to practice okay
and that's gonna be hard for both of you
I do think it's important for you if
when he is unplugging and checking out
and going off
it sounds like he gets depressed can I
tell you what it really is it's a temper
tantrum
okay it's a childish response to not
getting his way because he wanted the
baby to reach out and hug him and the
baby just screams and cries until mom
picks her up as a temper tantrum
and he's gonna have to decide all right
I'm not letting this three-month-old
have a vote into my life
and I'm gonna keep showing up because
I'm an adult and that's what adults do
we keep showing up we keep showing up we
keep showing up I'm gonna change the
diaper I'm gonna change the diaper I'm
gonna do it wrong she's gonna kick and
scream even when I'm doing it right
I'm gonna feed with the bottle and she's
gonna still scream for Mom and you're
gonna get frustrated and he's gonna get
but I'm gonna keep showing up and I'm
gonna keep showing up I'm gonna keep
showing up right that's what parenting
yes
and what you all need to have the
conversation you all can have is less
about how he's feeling because he's
going to practice over time not letting
this little girl hurt his heart right
because he's the adult and she's a child
what y'all you need to be clear with him
about is what you need on the show up
times even when you don't feel like
here's what I need you to show up here's
what I need you to show up even though
you don't feel like it I need you to
keep showing up does that make sense
that's maturity that's adults
yeah okay
um does he get hard to be around when he
gets depressive
or gets it gets pissy
he doesn't really get pissy he just gets
so sad like it hurts me like and I feel
so bad because I can't help him in those
moments yeah so this is a phrase that's
guilty it's gonna make the internet's
not too happy with me that's fine
he has to choose he's got to stop
choosing sadness
okay and that's hard because it's like
you can't choose that and she just feels
that I'm gonna choose
or when that initial oh my gosh my
daughter hates me then it's very clear
no she doesn't she's three months old
she's just hungry she's she is in her
what the fourth trimester right
she's still developing right she's a
yeah anyway that's a whole other
conversation he's got to start choosing
to to not just go down the rabbit hole
of sadness and worry and it's all coming
down and I suck at this and I hate my
daughter hates me she doesn't right no I
mean and she smiles at him when she
smiles at me like she loves him and it's
very obvious but then there's the moment
where she needs something and she can't
tell us and the switch flips so fast
yeah and yeah it's just a it's just a
big kid temper tantrum
um that that he's doing and so and I say
that like having done a million of them
myself
and also saying this on the back end of
this thing choosing like making the
affirmative decision I'm not gonna let
my kids hurt my feelings I'm gonna be
the adult in this interaction
my body relaxed
and kids pick up tension when you hold
the kid and you're tense they feel that
and it feels uncomfortable for them when
you're relaxed and you're hanging on to
them they it's they can settle into that
and kids pick up that angst and they
pick up that anxiety they pick up that
tense feeling those tense muscles am I
doing this right I don't know if I they
don't want to be around that
so when I quit giving kids access to my
soul like you don't get to hurt my
feelings then I'd be much more relaxed
and then when I'm much more relaxed kids
are much more likely to lean into that
and then with my daughter I've talked
about this on the show
like age three age four she was so all
about her mom especially during covid
which they were at home together and I
was at work she had nothing to do with
me and it really was heartbreaking like
she would say Daddy I don't ever want to
hug you ever
and I'd say that thank you for sharing
that with me and I'd go in my room and
be like I'm the worst right
and then just hang in there and I kept
showing up and I kept showing up and now
it's hug fest 2000. last night my wife
and I and my daughter went to get tacos
and burritos at this local joint here
and I saw my daughter
and dude it was she squeezed my neck off
my body and it felt so good in my soul
so tell your husband to come in it's
gonna come just he's got to keep showing
up he's got to keep showing up he's got
to choose choose joy and choose choose
choose to keep showing up great great
thank you so much I'm so grateful for
this call Jordan you're awesome